hello everybody my name is markiplier
and the last time that I played this
game which is cloudberry Kingdom you
guys said that it wasn't exactly a hard
game you know it didn't seem that
difficult it wasn't really a rage game
well sad to say you're wrong
shut up wide sad to say you're wrong
because this game is more of a nightmare
than it seems and it's a horrible
experience that I'm gonna subject myself
to for your entertainment so I'm gonna
try to beat one level one level if I can
be just one level you all owe me a drink
at the bar unless you're not old enough
to drink and then I don't know give me
one of your toys or something sending in
the mail but if I can't be one level
then I will do another challenge like
you know one of the cinnamon challenge
or something you guys got to come up
with that in the kit in the comments so
the pressure is on for this one if I
can't beat this yeah I got a new other
another challenge for you guys so this
is custom difficulty you can see I write
it random difficulty and here we are in
the level of nightmares actually this
one doesn't seem nearly as bad as some
of the ones I've seen so Amin I'm gonna
try this I got a minute hang on wait I
got oh hey I'll give me a second I got a
look at this but ah you giant turd goop
falling from the sky haha okay so I
almost got through the first platform
there aha wait a minute okay so no wait
hang on shut up everybody shut up hold
on almost got this hey you big swinging
ball come out of nowhere you always
catch me by surprise so oh alright I
can't hang on wait a minute I gotta keep
it I gotta keep a close eye on all of
the little things that are going around
while I'm trying to also avoid oh my god
oh come on I'm trying to this I'm not
used to the gamepad oh I thought it was
gonna die so I gave up and I don't know
what happened I don't know I don't know
those tiny fish do they even count I
don't even know if I hit those if they
actually kill me I have no idea
that'd be really stupid if they did
they're tiny Oh Oh sick moves oh you son
of a sharp wine god damnit nurse I don't
know who that is actually I didn't even
I don't know I don't know who that is
that's a number that I do not know
whatever I don't care stop texting me
I'm trying to concentrate because I
don't want to do another challenge here
we go ah mother fire okay hang on wait
no hang on wait whoa Wow ah you moved
you son of a [ __ ] oh come on I've got
these giant Turkey oh well there wasn't
even a platform there that was my own
fault god no no okay it's okay
hang on this is gonna take some skill
and ah come on mother hubbard fudging
nutters gotcha gotcha biznitch Oh I
thought I thought I was onto something
there ya know I gotta jump from there
that is stop stop being stupid please
okay go anyway yeah oh it's like a
trifecta of balls god there's so many
balls going into my face right now that
I can't even tell which way is up and
then the giant green turd goop comes
down and then I die oh and the criteria
I think for winning is I have to get all
the gems but I don't think that even
matters because I think that right now
the gems are just a clue to where I'm
actually supposed to go to win all
trifecta balls
god damn it these sons of [ __ ]
everywhere okay huh oh I kind of hurry
up through there but that little goop is
oh you big goof it's big goop sin little
goo the goop and me they're duping me
all in my face and I don't like it okay
Oh your turn god damn it well I'm glad
the music is changing got really helps
set the mood go I hope I don't go out of
my mind and kill somebody fluffer
nutters okay anyway so son of a [ __ ]
and yeah this is what I mean by the game
is random because this is just setting
up random variables and it is beatable
least or at least I think it is anyway
because it might not be I honestly have
no idea because you know it sets up a
random algorithm the computer determines
that
it is beautiful but I have no idea if
that's actually a fact son of a [ __ ]
how many times have I died god dammit
how am I supposed to be able to go
through there that's impossible
fine mr. Jemma god damn it oh you know
it's different than like say unfair
Mario because this game is actually
designed to be fair I mean you know it
may seem like it's hard but there is a
way through all I was almost a fighter
just hurried I stopped oh man okay if I
just got my Jeff oh god damn it get out
of my way I'm gonna stab someone yeah
Oh God you see guys oh it's it's told
all God if I keep getting caught on that
platform there that's what I not need to
do go go go go go go damn it you jump
when you explosive you leave when you
zags and you're zigged and you're wrong
I want those toys god damn it I'm just
standing that's how Santa gets all those
toys laughs a blockage I don't even know
I'm the timings all off him oh you jump
too early man you jump too early you
gotta keep calm just keep calm and carry
on boy
yeah baby yeah this is all your child
green goopy turds that's what you that's
all you are
god damn it's how does that help you
really do you think that's an at all
oh I'm gonna beat this I'm gonna get
everybody's toys and then god damnit
don't jump on the last platform get on
the damn block and then oh oh oh really
oh really oh oh no don't
haha okay it's good yeah I don't even
know if those oh I was so close
ah I don't even know how close I am I
said this game to be long so I may oh
why does sometimes that goes farther and
sometimes it goes not how is it going to
be more of a son of a [ __ ] I ask myself
wow just like oh just like the arrow
missed my aha crap oh love that music so
isn't that fantastic Oh got these
something beats in my head that tell me
that I'm not a failure but I am I'm a
failure over and over I'm a dishonor to
my people I should just quit life I
should quit life oh yes son of a [ __ ]
oh you're tired of it oh I didn't say
that it was a time limit on this thing I
could go for as long as I fricking want
to and you all got a watch you all got a
watch me slowly lose my mind oh there we
go there we go
this is it oh no u-turn u-turn goddamnit
oh I'm gonna lose my mind
I'm gonna lose my mind oh yeah I'm gonna
go home bah bah this isn't fair
I mean it's totally fair I mean there's
a waiver ha ha ha ha ha I'm turning
French again friendly one who have seen
my unfair Mario playthrough
I don't even know what accent I'm doing
now what he did I don't know I don't
even know I don't even care I don't want
to do anything I don't want to do
anything you bounced me off into the
abyss you son of a [ __ ] you sent me to
my doom you intention rose
yeah that's what I'm talking about
Bob yeah yeah Kenny died get it Oh what
giant what's up in the sky crapping on
my head why do I need this oh man this
is not some giant green Jolly Green
giant's baby I don't know god dammit god
dammit ah that's okay I'm fine I'm gonna
be fine just gonna carry on and be
awesome and everything I oh yeah oh yeah
whoo I know the big swinging ball that
wasn't a problem before god damn it
oh I just I'm saying hi to all the balls
and just making sure that they catch me
in the face that's all that I really
care about it's all that I want it's all
that I've ever wanted
Boing oh yeah this is the stuff this is
where the winners go [ __ ] man
God stop going [ __ ] hey got da ha ha ha
ha ha ha I don't even know what I'm
saying anymore so I'm about epileptics
squid on acid ion tongue I don't know
I'm not good at games they're not good
guy son of a [ __ ] okay you know what
I'm gonna watch the computer do it cuz I
don't think this is possible
that's what I was doing I'm doing that
yeah I was doing I did that I did that
and then I definitely did that
the OI doesn't jump there that's what it
do that's how it be he don't jump there
he just oh oh that's not cheating that
it totally counts well I mean I don't
know if it'll even help me because I
don't remember but whatever I've totally
forgotten how to play
no huh yeah that's one of the cool
features you can actually watch so that
you know that it's not actually
impossible it's it's walk walk walk walk
walk no no I met one okay whatever I
wasn't gonna get it anyway oh no the
ball nah nah don't tell me anyway Oh Bob
or another yeah all right yeah just like
oh no this is gonna helping me at all
it's actually quite distracting got ya
Wow look oh no you left me behind you
stupid red ball cap slightly ahead now
I'm slightly behind
oh no I'm behind behind I tell you [ __ ]
you ah too early too early ha yeah I
just need to be as awesome as I can boy
what ha I don't know when you stopped
and you are you left me you died me I'll
give
the
dragon Oh thought of it yeah boy boy
okay that's that's totally cheated okay
I gotta turn that up whoa that was so
weird
what happened everybody that I that's so
strange I just got this funny feeling
that a bunch of little kids are gonna be
sending me their toys no presents for
you this Christmas little no wait hang
on
no it all depends on if I could still
get through this next part that is the
determining factor doing the boring
thing that was totally in synchronous
orbit tough third okay everyone hold on
a second cuz somebody doesn't seem right
here I did this before I know wow this
is before you're a liar you dirty dirty
liar you're dirty liar that's what you
are and that's all you'll never be to me
oh I'm like a half a second behind oh
yeah I can't get it up there get it in
nurse Oh God
oh it's cyndago hang on that was that's
a test from cyndago I don't I don't care
about that that's really cool I love
those guys cyndago is awesome I was
following it doing it right on it Wow
what am I doing wrong I don't get it I'm
not I'm not doing anything wrong there
what is going on there yeah what what
I'm doing exactly that what are you
doing I'm oh I'm doing
am I really this was working before
there we go mother humper don't know I
mind
haha God the turd [ __ ] you
god dammit oh no no no God what am i
doing differently there I did that a
million times before and suddenly now if
it's tied to no be there why then though
haha oh no behind god's ball ah
nevermind you know what
Oh can you guys tell me what I'm doing
wrong there what in the world is
happening that I missing that why Nigel
why okay I'm on target kind of maybe oh
my god I'm off target God how do I keep
getting off target there guy a son of a
[ __ ] I hate you so much what is what
what was that what that's never happened
before what the hell why did you
suddenly decide to go rocketing oh oh
you do do that
oh okay here we go
no I'm off target again yeah okay wait
hope and then boy knee and then kabuki
and then about it to win it no what did
you just do you did something
differently oh my god it's doing it
differently wow wow what happened
I made it guys that was so weird
well a deal's a deal now all of you
deserve to buy me a drink and or send me
one of your toys your favorite childhood
toy give it to me I want it I want all
of it I did that totally legitimately
and I only died 172 times Wow anyway you
guys got to see oh no oh no Jim I missed
three gems who's cheating I didn't get
it
not that I was
so I guess I don't do to get cut I guess
I don't get your toys and or drinks oh I
guess I gotta do a challenge alright
okay so there you have it I lost even
though I won even though I cheated so
I'm a man of my word you come up with a
challenge that you want me to do I'll do
it all right
totally thank you all so much for
watching click in Jason for videos it
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
you can tell
nature of the day
the protagonist
Wow